en annonçant ma candidature à la mairie
de paris
je connaissais la dureté de la vie
politique depuis plus d'un an
ma famille et moi avons subi des propos
diffamatoires des mensonges s'attaque
anonyme
la révélation de conversations privées
dérobés ainsi que des menaces de mort ce
torrent de boue m'a affecté mais il a
surtout fait du mal à ce que j'aime
comme si cela n'était pas suffisant hier
un nouveau stade a été franchie un site
internet et des réseaux sociaux ont
relayé des attaques ignobles mettant en
cause ma vie privée
ma famille ne mérite pas cela personne
au fond
on ne devrait jamais subir une telle
violence
en ce qui me concerne
je ne souhaite pas nous exposer
davantage ma famille et moi quand tous
les coups sont désormais permis
cela va trop loin
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de retirer ma
candidature à l'élection municipale
parisienne
cette décision me coûte mais mes
priorités sont très claires c'est
d'abord la famille vous l'aurez compris
et puis c'est le projet pour paris celui
que nous avons construit pour lequel
nous sommes beaucoup battus ce projet
aujourd'hui il vivra mieux sans moi
merci aux équipes de campagne qui ne
comptent pas leurs heures
depuis tant de mois merci au co listière
et aux colistiers pour leur engagement
merci à toutes celles et à tous ceux qui
participent à cette formidable aventure
les parisiens méritent une campagne dit
je vous remercie